[Music]
all right good morning everyone so in
this session we will talk about coop
flow pipelines and how it can help you
accelerate development of production
machine learning applications my name is
Anand IRA and I am a product manager in
the Google cloud AI platform team we're
very fortunate to have as my
co-presenter vilem Pinar from go check
go check is a fast growing customer of
Google Cloud and vilem is a lead data
scientist at go check and he'll talk
about how they leveraged coop flow
pipelines for a real-world production
machine learning use case for the first
20 minutes or so I'll give you an
overview of coop flow pipelines and then
I'll hand things over to vilem for the
more interesting part of the
presentation which includes a demo
towards the very end we will have a Q&A
session we'll be taking questions from
all of you and in fact while the session
is going on you can start adding your
questions to the Dory Q&A app I'll give
you a couple seconds to actually quickly
look at the instructions for adding
questions to the door yep all right with
that let's get started
so first let me start with the
motivation behind coop flow pipelines
why did we start this project in the
first place we started this project
because building and deploying real
world machine learning applications is
hard and costly because of the lack of
tooling for the end-to-end development
and deployment lifecycle or end to end
process let me elaborate on that a
little bit often when we talk about
building a machine learning application
we're talking about developing the the
core model and the model development
happens with libraries like tensorflow
and python scikit-learn extra boost and
so forth so we often we talk about
developing the model and then deploying
the model and yes absolutely that is at
the heart of developing a machine
learning application but when you are
building deploying and
a machine learning application in
production that entails many other
stages a production machine learning
application is often running
continuously it's running 24/7 by 365
data is coming in on a regular basis
either streaming in or coming in as
batches on on periodic intervals models
have to be constantly updated and
improved upon and deployed and of course
before you deploy any newly trained
model you have to make sure the new
models are safe for deployment for the
data that is streaming in you have to do
data pre-processing and data validation
and make sure that there are no data
quality issues then after that you do
feature engineering followed by model
training with hyper parameter tuning
followed by model validation and so on
and so forth so what is needed is simple
tooling the orchestrate and manage these
multi-phase machine learning workflows
and the ability to run them reliably and
repeatedly and that is the problem that
coop flow pipelines aims to solve so
actually before we move on I I should
call out that this diagram it's not a
new diagram we created it's actually
from a fairly seminal Google paper that
was authored a few years back that talks
about the hidden debt in building
machine learning applications so
actually we would like to have a quick
show of hands to see if folks have
actually seen this diagram or something
similar before so please raise your
hands if you've seen it all right well
that's actually quite a few of you so I
possibly I am preaching to the choir
here but but that's awesome all right so
before we get into the specifics of coop
flow pipelines I want to provide a
little bit more context coop flow
pipelines is part of the open source
coop flow project open source coop flow
is a seamlessly integrated collection of
tools and services for the full
production machine learning lifecycle
everything from distributed scalable
model training to deploying a models for
online serving at scale to jupiter
notebooks with jupiter hub and then
workflow orchestration and metadata and
workflow management with coop flow
pipelines and so
and so forth so coop flow pipelines is a
part of this larger open source project
called coop flow coop flow services are
built to run on top of kubernetes and we
chose kubernetes as the underlying
platform because at this point
kubernetes is almost the de facto for
anything that entails cluster compute at
scale so kubernetes provides the
scalability and it also enables hybrid
deployments because coop flow can run on
any kubernetes cluster so that cluster
can be running on Google Cloud or it can
be running on print on Prem or multiple
other clouds and of course with the
anthis announcement made two days back
you can actually run coop flow on top of
Anthes and help Anthes manage these
deployments in multiple environments of
course four on Google Cloud coop flow is
easy to deploy with Google kubernetes
engine or anthos and in many cases for
applications authored with the coop flow
SDKs you can run them on fully managed
services in the cloud AI platform so I
wanted to provide that bit of context
before we dove into the specifics of
coop flow pipelines
now the capability is provided by coop
flow pipelines can largely be put under
three buckets machine learning workflow
orchestration sharing reusability and
easy composability and rapid reliable
experimentation so let's start with the
first one machine learning work workflow
orchestration to make things more
concrete let's look at a screen shot of
a workflow that was run with coop flow
pipelines so for any workflow that you
run with coop flow pipelines you get
this rich visual depiction of the
topology of the workflow so you can see
that and understand what was wrong of
course this is just an illustrative
machine learning workflow of course when
you build your own machine learning
workflows you can have all sorts of
different topologies for a given step of
the workflow you can use your own tools
and libraries of choice a given step of
the workflow can be a single node
instance that can run with different
types of hardware GPUs and CPUs or it
can also be a given step can be
something that runs in a distributed
fashion so long story short this is just
an illustrative workflow
course you can build all sorts of
interesting to apologies and
applications and architectures now let's
look at this specific example in this
particular examples to make things more
concrete this particular example it
starts with a data pre-processing and
data validation step followed by a
feature engineering step and after that
we're forking out and running training
three different kinds of models in
parallel and each of these model
training nodes encapsulate hyper
parameter tuning within it then after
that we take the best models trained in
each of these Forks and run them on a
test data set and analyze them and
compare them and then pick the best
model and if that model happens to meet
our performance threshold we can deploy
it to an online serving endpoint so that
is an example of the type of work flows
you can build and deploy with coupe flow
pipelines for each step of the workflow
you actually have access to all the
relevant metadata and metrics at your
fingertips so as an example if you let's
take the training step if it produced an
ROC curve you can visualize it right
there or if it produced the rich
metadata that can be visualized through
tensor board density board is just one
click away so long story short all the
relevant information that you need is
available right there at your fingertips
for each step of the workflow you have
access to the configuration parameters
that were passed in and you can also see
what were the inputs to that step and
what were the outputs produced so for
any model trained with coupe flow
pipelines you will not have to wonder or
you won't have the problem of not being
able to answer how that model was
produced because for any model train
with goop flow pipelines you can go back
to the corresponding execution run and
you have all the relevant information at
your fingertips and this is particularly
important for production machine
learning workflows so now let's take a
peek under the hood and let's try to
understand what exactly constitutes a
coupe flow pipeline so goop flow
pipeline consists of multiple steps and
each step of the coupe flow pipeline is
a containerized task we're talking about
production machine learning workflows
and contain
are the industry-standard solution for
portability for repeatability and
encapsulation of dependency so we don't
want to reinvent the wheel that's why we
built a solution that leverages
containers at the heart of it and of
course because this it gets deployed on
kubernetes of course we were going to
choose containers now as I mentioned
previously each step of the workflow can
be very heterogeneous can run on
different types of hardware it can be a
simple Python script or something that
runs in a distributed fashion it can be
an apache spark job or it could be a
distributed model training job steps of
the workflow can also call out to other
Google services so those are the steps
of the workflow now the other key aspect
of the the workflow is the definition of
the sequence or the topology of the
workflow the sequence in which the steps
should run and how the data flows
between these steps how to connect the
outputs of one step with the inputs of
downstream steps and then the third
aspect of defining a pipeline is
defining the set of input parameters
that the end user has to provide
so the containerized steps or each step
packaged as a container the definition
of the workflow topology and the
specification of the input parameters
together constitute a cube flow pipeline
so now let's see how you offer a coop
flow pipeline when we spoke to the
target audience data scientists and
machine learning engineers in machine
learning practitioners time and again
everyone said Python is their preferred
lingua franca so we said okay let's
provide an SDK that is fairly intuitive
and native to Python coders so and
that's what we've provided you get a
fairly intuitive Python SDK that you use
to specify the topology of your workflow
and specifying the topologies as is it's
basically as simple as calling Python
functions that represent the various
steps of your workflow and connecting
them with inputs and outputs I won't go
into too many details of the Python SDK
and actually in the the next section of
the talk will him as he's doing his demo
we'll provide more details about the SDK
and of course the SDK is a broad topic
in and of itself so you know I request
you to look at the the coop flow
pipelines documentation to learn more
about the SDK now at this point you may
be wondering but wait a minute I said
each step of the workflow is a
containerized task and here I'm talking
about defining
work flow with a Python SDK and calling
the steps like Python function so
there's some disconnect here valid
observation in its simplest form because
we're arcus trading containers as long
as the containers follow a protocol on
how they accept inputs and how they
produce outputs any containerized tasks
can be converted into a workflow step
and so that provides flexibility in fact
we have a customer that is that has
taken Fortran libraries that do
numerical analysis put them in a
container and call that particular
container as a task in a cube flow
workflow so this provides a lot of
flexibility the ability to take a
containerized task and convert it into a
step of workflow and the way you do that
is you define a Python function wrapper
for that container by invoking this SDK
function called the container ops you
call the container op and you convert
the Python wrapper function that you can
now use while you're defining the
workflow topology but we realize that
our target audience data scientists and
machine learning practitioners they
don't come in and build docker
containers on on a daily basis or rather
they're not directly dealing with docker
on a daily basis and in many cases for
the most part and will continue to
improve upon this for the most part the
docker ization becomes an implementation
detail so if you're writing a step of
the workflow with Python we provide
simple utilities and function decorators
to take your Python code and package it
up automatically as a containerized task
that you can call as a step of the
workflow so Keith key aspect here is
while under the hood each task is a
container for the most part machine
learning practitioners and data
scientists will deal with their Python
code and we take care of the mechanics
of docker ization we simplify the docker
ization for you and of course if you're
running it on google cloud you are going
to call and leverage google clouds
amazing fully managed solutions for data
analytics and machine learning model
training and so forth and for these
services we give you out-of-the-box
connectors so again you don't have to
focus on the mechanics of calling out to
these services we simplify that for you
you focus on your code and you use these
out-of-the-box connectors and of course
we will continue to improve upon this
story
all right so now let's look at the
second key value proposition of coop
flow pipelines which is sharing
reusability and composability and the
key premise here is most machine
learning applications today they're
built as bespoke applications but as
machine learning becomes more mainstream
it becomes a more a key aspect of yeah
it goes mainstream as a key aspect
embedded into multiple applications you
need a faster way to build machine
learning applications and the best way
to do that is the ability to reuse what
others the great work that others have
done you don't want to always start from
scratch if someone else has built an
amazing workflow or an amazing component
that can be used as a part of the
workflow we want to enable that so we
want you to be able to find it easily
quickly and reuse it and you're good to
go and of course you'll customize it for
your specific needs so with good flow
pipelines
once you've defined the workflow you can
package it up as a zip file and that zip
file can be shared with others and they
can run it on their own coop flow
cluster and because each task is
containerized you're not worried about
the portability so package up your coop
flow pipeline as a zip file and give it
to say let's just say you develop the
the workflow on your development cluster
and you've tested it looks good and you
want to hand it off to the production
team that's deployed that will deploy it
on the production cluster grid just
package it up as a zip file and hand it
over to them and often what you want to
do is if you're working say in a large
organization or you're part of a broader
community you want to build an amazing
application and share it with others so
that they can leverage it and run it and
build upon it so if I would find a coop
flow application packages a zip file
from someone else I can load it up in my
coop flow cluster and I will get this UI
a UI form that has automatically created
based on the inputs accepted by that
pipeline
I'll get that UI form and without having
to write too much code I can actually
fill in the parameters of the UI form
and I can try out a coop flow
application very easily so that's a key
aspect of being able to reuse and
quickly try out the work that someone
else has done and this reusability is
not just for full end-to-end machine
learning workflows or a complete
pipeline we've actually made it such
that an individual step of a workflow
can be packaged
up as a reusable component so let's just
say you're doing some very interesting
feature engineering or you've come up
with a very interesting way to do model
analysis that you want everyone within
your organization to follow well great
author that as a usable coop flow
pipeline component and they can use it
easily within their own custom workflows
and because we're talking about reuse
and share I have to give a shout out to
the AI hub it's a product we launched
publicly yesterday and the AI hub is
your one-stop shop for sharing and
discovery of relevant machine learning
assets it has multiple times of types of
machine learning assets from models to
notebooks and so forth and of course a
noteworthy category of assets in a I
hope will be coop flow pipelines and
coop flow pipeline components and just
to make things more concrete I want to
give you an example of how easy it is to
find a reusable component in the AI hub
and use it as a part of your own custom
machine learning custom coop flow
pipeline it literally is a couple lines
of code so you first start with this
'lord component statements you go to the
a I hope you find your coop flow Piper
and usable component there'll be a copy
URL button you hit the copy URL button
you get that URL you then use it in this
load component statement and you get the
Python function representation of that
step and now you can use that step as a
part of your workflow when you're
defining your workflow so long story
short this whole aspect of reusing the
the great work that others have done or
if you have done you've done great work
being able to share that with others is
a key aspect of what coop flow pipelines
in conjunction with AI hub aims to
enable and that's a key aspect of
scaling out production machine learning
now let's talk about the third key value
proposition of coop flow pipelines and
and to motivate this actually we want to
call out a quote from one of the winners
of the latest caddel one million prize
competition so the one of the members of
the team that won the competition said
that for every idea that work they tried
hundred ideas that fail and that is the
nature of mural production machine
learning it's a it's an applied science
you have to try many different ideas to
find the ones that will work on your
data for your application so long story
short we want to
make it easy for you to rapidly iterate
on your ideas but do so in a reliable
and manageable way so for any workflow
or pipeline that is run on the coop flow
pipelines environment on a cupful
pipeline or noku flow cluster you get
the full historical view of all the
prior runs as well as your current runs
not only that you actually have
filtering and search functionality to
quickly find a past run and once you
find a pasture on that you're interested
in of course you'll have all the
relevant metrics and metadata config
parameters and so forth at your
fingertips and then you can hit the
clone button and create a clone of that
workflow and just run that clone if you
just want to repeat a prior exit
experimental run or you can clone it
you'll get the UI form that shows all
the input parameters and you can tweak
the input parameters and launch a
slightly different variant of this
workflow to try a different idea so
we've made it very easy to hit the clone
button tweak the variant with different
configuration parameters and run it and
in the future we'll actually extend that
to enable rapid iteration with the code
pertaining to a specific step of the
workflow as well so right now you can do
rapid iteration with configuration
parameter changes and in the future we
want to enable that for code changes as
well so at this point you know you've
done rapid iteration you've launched
many different variants of your workflow
to see what works best for your data for
your use case so let's just say you have
20 30 or more different executions of
course most of those are actually going
to fail not every execution is going to
result in you know the desired metrics
so now you have this long list of
experiments and in the ListView of these
experimental runs you get to see the
most important metrics right there in
the ListView so if you've got say 20 30
different execution runs you can quickly
hone in on the ones that perform well or
produce interesting results and ignore
the ones that didn't perform well or
didn't have interesting results select
the ones that are interesting select the
subset of experiments that are
interesting and then hit the compare
runs button to get a side-by-side
comparison
of these execution runs and you can do a
side-by-side comparison of the different
config committers and metrics and so on
and so forth so you can quickly hone in
on what was different about these
execution of runs you can quickly hone
in on the technique or the idea that led
to interesting results so that's how we
enable rapid reliable experimentation
it's reliable because the workflow
itself is you know backed by containers
which can be run
you know repeatedly all your relevant
config parameters and metrics are right
there at your fingertips
all right so those were the key features
a cool flow pipelines that I wanted to
provide as an overview I do want to
mention that we have quite a few
customers using coop flow pipelines we
have the card labs it's possible some of
you actually caught their presentation I
think two days back they use it for
interesting work on satellite images we
also have carousel and e-commerce
company using it for ranking of images
and scoring images and tagging them with
relevant metadata and so forth we have
Baker Hughes using coop flow pipelines
for workflows on industrial data or
metrics collected from oil and gas rigs
and so forth and lastly because coop
flow pipelines is open source we
actually have a vast ecosystem of
partners contributing to it we have
Intel that has four as an example Intel
has contributed components to coop flow
pipelines particularly a component that
makes it easy to take models and run
them on Intel's open V no runtime and
with that I'd like to pass things over
the velum thanks aunt
hello everybody my name is Willem and I
lead the data science platform team at
Gajic so we're an engineering team
embedded within data science at kojic
and our main focus is building and
implementing the tools the products the
platform on which data science and
machine learning operates at Gajic so
today I'm going to be talking a little
bit about some of the pains we had
scaling our data and ml pipelines and
how cube the pipeline's helped us to
address some of those pains so who or
what is go jack
Scott Jake is an Indonesian technology
startup we we were most famous for ride
hailing or motorcycles but we've since
launching that product a few years ago
we've branched into many different
products and services so ride hailing on
cars food delivery with go food
logistics with go box and go send
digital payments with go pay and many
other lifestyle services so today we are
in 15 different verticals and we have 19
different services that bother up into
one super app and there's one singular
goal and that is to solve every work
they need that you have so a little bit
about our scale Gajic is originally an
Indonesian company but we've now
expanded into Southeast Asia into many
other countries application has been
downloaded 125 million times or more
just in Indonesia alone one of our
products ago food is one of the largest
food delivery services in Southeast Asia
with over 400,000 merchants on the
platform
like I said we're in four different
countries right now Singapore Vietnam
and Thailand coming online in the last
year so ride-hailing service has more
than 2 million drivers on the platform
with hundreds of thousands of which are
there online at any given point in time
and we process more than a hundred
million book books every month so the
scale is quite large and the ability for
us to impact the company with data
science machine learning is quite great
so I want to talk about one of the first
challenges that we faced at kadjic with
with machine learning and data science
and that was finding a right driver or
it's a classic problem in ride hailing
and that is dispatcher allocation which
driver do you send to a customer when
they want to make a booking when they're
making a booking so this is an important
question because the amount of
transactions that are processed by a
ride hailing company like Gajic a system
that makes this decision can have a very
big impact on the bottom line of the
company if you working but millions of
orders every month so this was one of
the first things the data science team
needed to solve this bogus system that
could decide which driver to st. to a
customer and we originally started with
one North storm metric and that metric
was conversion so what is the likelihood
that the successful trip will be
completed between a specific pair of the
customer and a driver and so when we
when we set out to build the system we
looked at that single singular objective
and then as a data science platform team
and as a data science team we came
together and we built the systems that
actually could deploy this model into
serving environment so we implemented
airflow for our data pipelines and
machine learning pipelines and we
implemented kubernetes for our model
serving there scientists were going to
work in building the pipelines that
transformed and trained models draws
from the data and train the models and
they deployed it into this the serving
and we integrated with the Gajic
back-end and it worked well the backend
would send us lists drivers we rewrite
those drivers according to most
likelihood of converting and we choose
the top driver in most cases and there
was an uplift in conversion so we all
thought it was a job well done
we made an impact to the bottom line but
it turns out that our needs are actually
greater than that greater than just a
single model and the thing we realized
was that machine learning should provide
many levers to a business and in this
case we had provided only a single lever
and that was an objective of conversion
but actually in a ride-hailing company
that does ride-hailing it's actually a
marketplace so there's customers and
drivers meeting in this marketplace and
the many different things you can
optimize for you can
for business metrics like conversion
acceptance cancellation costs or profit
you can optimize for the customer
experience you can optimize for the
drivers opportunities and the fairness
of assigning the work because they're
ultimately employed or at least earning
an income through this platform so we
knew that we needed to support more
types of objectives in our system not
just conversion and we needed to be able
to experiment in a more granular way so
in a different time and place you want
to be able to let's say optimize for
cancellation and conversion and another
place optimize for the drivers
experience or their opportunities so
what we then decided to do was improve
our system make this this driver
allocation system and multi objective
system that has many different sub
components many different models and
then that would allow us to or a more
granular level decide on a very request
basis what weighting of an objective to
is to rank these drivers on and this
worked a k4 our serving layer because
it's a relatively solvable problem
building an ensemble hybrid system like
this but we turned it turns out that
taking our existing pipelines in airflow
and scaling it up to meet the needs of a
generic multi market multi-service multi
objective system was actually very very
difficult and was difficult for three
key reasons that I'll share with you now
so the first reason was it was very
difficult for us to experiment so it's
the typical workflow of data scientist
is one of starting in a notebook and
they will do their development and then
they'll get up to a certain point where
they there feel comfortable with
something that they've made maybe
they've training a model and they see
some good performance and they wonder
productionize it they won't get into
production because often with
ride-hailing you only prove the model
once it gets into production and not an
offline in a notebook so they're always
keen to get it into production as
quickly as possible and when you
transfer this code and rewrite it into
airflow
one of the things that that happened in
our experience was that it become it
became tightly coupled to airflows model
of operators and so experimentation went
from the notebook to airflow and airflow
is great at doing data processing and
it's really meant for that use case of
transforming data and updating
partitions in the query or a data store
but we're talking about an ml use case
we struggle to scale up to the needs of
our multi objective multi market multi
regional system so in ml use case you
want to quickly iterate on your
pipelines you want to quickly inject
configuration or data quickly add
variants you know try ten simpler XG
boost and see the results and evaluate
the results but this was very difficult
because of the fact that airflow is
based on chronological or time-based
runs
mean for scheduling and so variants
within ever was kind of tricky for us to
do and so what ended up happening is we
had we fought a lot of the the workflows
were being forked and the cross ended up
growing and it was a lot of duplication
of work so the experimentation was very
tough for us the second problem we had
was there was a lot of boilerplate code
being written and this was purely due to
the fact that the orchestration layer
the platform itself didn't provide this
abstraction to the end-user and so we
knew that we needed to solve this to
allow the data scientist to focus more
on actually the modeling and their what
their specialty is and the third thing
that we were having a pain with was
traceability and reproducibility so with
our system we didn't have a means of
injecting dependencies so data or
configuration or any kind of variance so
what would end up happening is the data
scientist would retrieve these
dependencies as side inputs in their
pipelines and these side inputs were
almost always untracked and it led to us
with having very little reproducibility
because if we rerun and pipeline and the
society inputs had changed in the
meantime
then you get different outputs so we
knew we needed a way to solve this
problem of side inputs and
dependencies in our pipelines and so we
looked at a lot of the tools that were
available to us outside and we were
already on GCP and one of the tools that
we and systems that we evaluated was
cupola pipelines for this use case and
it the way we ended up approaching and
solving this problem was as follows
so for experimentation we introduced cue
flow for the ML pipeline part of of our
data plan ml pipelines so we split our
pipelines into two we still use air flow
for our data transformations and
publishing to a feature store and this
feature store then becomes the interface
between our ml pipelines and our data
pipelines so now this has the effect of
allowing your email pipelines to be less
data focused even though they're still
occasionally some transformations
they're the pipeline's are a lot smaller
and they run a lot faster and with you
pipelines you can spin up many different
pipeline instances runs and you can
inject parameters into those runs and
you can even do it from a notebook so
you can quickly do a lot of
experimentation rapidly and compare
these results very easily to reduce the
amount of boilerplate code we introduced
cue flow components to our data
scientists and our users so these
components are pre-built by Google and a
lot of them already exist we can use to
use api's or data Pro core any kind of
systems for common operations that you
can can do in your cue flow pipelines
but you can also author your own custom
components and this allows us to as an
engineering team abstract the users away
from common operations like retrieving
data from features stores or publishing
to our custom in-house deployment
environments or anything like that so
this is how we solve a party solve some
of the engineering challenges and
abstracted those away and then finally
one of the key things in couplet
pipelines that's very useful is the
parameterization of the pipeline itself
which was lacking in our existing
orchestration system so
by allowing parameterization if you took
if he's trace the inputs to a pipeline
and if you if you track the actual
pipeline that executed and if those
inputs are immutable then you
automatically get things like a
traceability reproducibility and
deterministic runs and this was one of
the key things that we need it because
if you're tracking the metadata of a
pipeline and that model goes in the
model that it produces goes into
production and it performs well or
doesn't perform well you want to be able
to go upstream again and back and see
why what why that was right what may
lead to that model performing well or
poorly but let's go to a quick demo
where I can show you
couplet pipelines in a little bit more
detail so this is the cube flow
pipelines user interface and if you
click on the pipeline section it takes
you to some of the pre-built pipelines
you'll see the ones the sample ones are
the ones that are just given to us when
you deploy key flow pipelines I've built
one pipeline here and plated already
which we'll have a look at shortly so
these pipelines are essentially
templates they're not runs or pipelines
that have executed in the past but we
can run them we can start them as as
execution runs with our parameters so
I'm gonna click into this one that I've
built for allocation so this is a very
simple pipeline a very simple example to
just illustrate how couplet pipelines
work so what you can see here is
multiple steps in a pipeline the
retrieval of features from a feature
store a training of a model the bullying
of prediction set evaluation of that
state and then publishing of that
painting on the evaluation criteria so
if you click into one of these tasks one
of these steps each step is an a docker
image that will be run as a container so
you can actually see at the bottom of
this page the docker image that will be
run so queue for pipelines also tells
you which input parameters will be sent
to this pipeline and how how sorry to
this step and how these inputs will map
to docker container so the fact that
this is a docker image an intoxicant
runnin docker container means that
development debugging testing is very
easy you could do this all flyness
actually can be done in a way that is
completely decoupled from cue flow
itself and it's and it's you also don't
really have any kind of lock into key
flow so if you're moving from cute
flirty airflow that that process will be
simple so so this example one more thing
that I wanted to show you here is that
you can actually see that the inputs map
from one task one step into another and
this this specific graph has been bought
by both from a notebook and published
previously but I'll go into a little bit
more detail later and showing you how to
build this from a notebook so if you
have a pipeline already registered with
key flow pipelines you can create an
instance of it by clicking on create run
so you can give you a pipeline run and a
name and you can choose an experiment an
experiment being nothing more than a
grouping of comparable runs but for us
and in terms of the three problems we
had was rapid experimentation being the
first and the third being the
traceability the key thing that we
needed was being able to inject these
parameters into our runs and so this
section is really critical for us is is
the being able to generalize our
pipeline extract the complexities and
the things that that change and create
parameters from them and that allows us
to more easily scale to many markets
because we can have parameters to define
service types or the region where a
specific pipeline should be that it
should be targeting and so these
parameters were really key for us so
instead of looking at these parameters I
can actually show you the note that
created this pipeline so if you click on
the side here on the notebooks button
it'll actually directly to a jupiter
instance running in the same queue
Bernays cluster so when you deploy cube
flow it actually deploys a jupiter
deployment with that cupola pipelines
deployment and these two are are able to
communicate with each other and it's a
little bit more abstract from main user
so if you click on this this pre-built
notebook that I have here for us I can
walk you through the process of creating
and offering this pipeline so how this
works is you
you initially start with some steps of
housekeeping and defining some global
variables one of which that is important
is defining your cue flow SDK package
and then once you have that URL you can
just install it with poop so the
installation is super easy and then
you're ready to go so the first thing we
do is we define or we connect this cute
Fleur client or this ACK to our local
keeper pipelines cluster or sorry our
deployment it'll automatically find the
keep up pipelines deployment if it's in
the same cluster if it's in a remote
cluster or if you're working on a local
environment you need to specify a URL
then you specify an experiment name and
this name in our case we'll just be
allocation because that's what we're
trying to solve so this will just be a
grouping and if you actually go back to
the experiments that are available here
I've already done some runs and they are
already and there are some historic runs
already existing so the next step is
defining the pipeline this is the
critical part of actually using Cupid
pipelines and there are basically two
steps to this the first is defining the
operations that will be executed and
then secondly is connecting those up
into a graph so what we do is I think
what a nun was talking about earlier is
calling this class of container off and
creating instances of these operations
and we pass in the arguments that we
wanted to find us
what makes this container operation
unique and the two most important parts
here which docker image will be running
and what will be the arguments that we
send to that docker image and again this
makes debugging and testing and
development very easy because you can
taste the specific operation the step in
your pipeline independently of queue
flow pipelines you also need to give it
a name and give it just tell it where
output data will be available once it's
completed and we wrap this all container
operation in a function call because
this makes calling this or creating
instances of this operation later a
little bit simpler so in this case we've
got five of these operations retrieval
features the training of a model
prediction creating a prediction set and
then evaluate an evaluation step with an
ROC curve
and the publishing of the model and now
the most important part is defining the
pipeline so here we it's nothing more
than a function call so which is called
the allocation pipeline and the two
important parts here would be first
defining the input parameters and these
arguments to the function call actually
become the parameters that are available
to you here so if you go back to the
pipeline that we've created and you
create a run these parameters that are
available to you actually come from the
arguments of this this function call so
this is great for us in a lot of ways
because often we're authoring these
pipelines and the end users are not
coders they're just maybe business users
or analysts that just want to do some
analysis or just explore what an impact
the model can have and just experiment a
bit so by publishing this this and
compiling this workflow into something
that can be deployed to keep the
pipelines
end users can just use a user interface
and interact with the system like that
they don't need to be able to code so
then we decorate this function call with
keeper pipelines decorator and give it a
name and description and then
importantly we define the steps and here
we've got a feature retrieval step so we
just call the function where you define
already we specify the input parameters
these input parameters or the same ones
semi ones that are coming into this
function call and here's the important
part the the second step is the training
step and it depends on the first step
because you're mapping the output from
the first step into this second step so
you're not actually building the grow
the grow off directly but you're
specifying inputs and outputs and once
once you've completed these steps you
can you can compile this pipeline and
I'll do that right now so I've compiled
this pipeline and this allocation zip
file will be available in this Jupiter
environment and and and this can be
submitted to keep flow and once you've
submitted it it'll be available here as
part of the pipelines but a more
interesting way that I've that we've
reused skip flow pipelines with is
actually starting the runs using this
allocation or this compiled pipeline
from the notebook so the cue flow SDK
the pipeline City SDK allows you to run
a pipeline
directly so you can just specify
experiment and give you a pipeline run a
name specify the pipeline and then
inject the parameters and this allows
for that rapid experimentation so in
this case what I'm going to do is I'm
going to start a run and one of the
parameters will be a list of features
that we want to send into that run and
we've also got a target of what - - of
this which objective we're optimizing
for so I can start a run here and it'll
create a little run link for us and I
can delete a bunch of these features and
I can run that again and now I've got
two runs that haven't been executed like
imagine if you want to experiment very
quickly you can have a for loop there
you can do a grid search or parameter
search you can spin up 105 lines if you
want to and compare them and keep the
pipeline's so I'm just going to do this
just use those features but if we go to
cue plop I plants and we go to our
experiments you can see that there are
not two runs running here click on one
of these feature retrieval has really
happened
it's output a data set and you can see
the inputs and our parameters to this
step I've click on the training we can
see that this datasets already been
loaded by the training step this is a
specific docker container of this
running inside of this kubernetes
cluster and you get all the benefits of
cuber Nettie's because it's running on a
cuban haze cluster so as engineers this
allows us to build platforms on this on
this existing tooling click on the logs
you'll see that training is already
running but for our use case I think
I'll show you some of the previously
executed runs so if we click on this run
this is a completed run I can show you
some of the functionality that I learned
was speaking about earlier so one of the
interesting things that you can see is
of course the inputs and aquas to each
step but also the output artifacts that
are available to you so one of the
output artifacts that we have available
to us here is at the evaluation stage
we're step is an ROC curve so there's an
end user you can easily draw into this
curve and evaluate the performance of
the specific run but just doing this on
a single run is not really that
interesting it's it's useful but a more
powerful way to do this is to look at
multiple of these runs together so we
can actually click on multiple of these
runs and compare them together and you
can see that anything that varies here
is
the input parameters of the list of
features so here we have more or less
features for each of these runs
everything else is constant so what cube
flow pipelines does is it actually shows
you the output artifacts at each stage
that has the same name but also shows
you an aggregated view so here you get
an aggregated view of all three of these
runs so you as a user can drill into the
performance of these runs and compare
and contrast them so if you're spending
up many pipelines you can quickly
compare them and even end-users that are
not developers can quickly compare them
and some more of the pipe or pipeline
artifacts output artifacts that I want
to show you is captured in ATF X
pipeline here so this is a bit more of a
complicated run it does it has more
steps to it so this is using the New
York City Taxi data and it's a tazer
flow model that it's training so some of
the other artifacts that can be produced
for example as a confusion matrix so
this matrix is great for a quickly
analyzing a classifier we've also got a
table which is a very practical thing to
expose to end-users you can just quickly
get a sample of data and expose it to
the end-user they don't need to open up
the query or any kind of CSV file on GCS
one of my favorite output artifacts is
just a static HTML as an engineer this
unlocks a lot of doors because now we
can embed any HTML and JavaScript and
render anything within Cooper pipelines
for our end users all we need to do is
both at the docker image that produces
those so in this case the end user can
quickly analyze the model itself and
just use this existing static HTML and
data set and then a more powerful thing
that was showcasing earlier is the fact
that we have tensor boards available to
us so at the training step we can
actually click on open tensor board it's
one of the artifacts that's produced and
the end user can then draw into this and
in more detail analyze their their model
and the specific tensorflow run the
distributions histograms and anything
like that
so I'd implore you to have a look at
cute flow pipelines and in fact if we go
back to our presentation
you can easily deploy a key flow pipe
lines using the deployed cute little
cloud it's very simple it'll only take
you one or two minutes to do that and
yeah I encourage you to give it a go
Thanks
[Applause]
[Music]